IS CALLED RELIABLE SOURCES.
HILARIOUS.
EVERY SINGLE HOUSE DEMOCRAT
EXCEPT ONE IS BACKING A BILL
THAT WOULD REQUIRE ALL HIGH
SCHOOLS NATIONWIDE TO LET
BIOLOGICAL MEN COMPETE ON WOMEN
SPORTS TEAMS.
TO MOST PEOPLE THAT SEEMS
INSANE, AND TWO FEMALE ATHLETES
OF COURSE IT IS GROSSLY UNFAIR.
BUT NOW, IT'S ITS ORTHODOXY.
SCIENCE AND COMMON SENSE ARE
IRRELEVANT.
MEANWHILE, A TAXPAYER FUND AND
STUDY SPONSORED BY THE NIH,
NATIONAL NIH, NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH IS ALLOWING
SEX CHANGE HORMONES TO BE GIVEN
TO CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS EIGHT
YEARS OLD.
SO WHAT ARE THE EFFECTS OF THAT?
DO WE KNOW?
DR. MARC SIEGEL IS HERE TONIGHT.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR COMING ON.
SO WHENEVER YOU HAVE AN
ADVANCEMENT IN CULTURE THAT
NOBODY IS ALLOWED TO QUESTION
AND THEN IT BLEEDS OVER INTO
SCIENCE, IT MAKES ME NERVOUS, NO
MATTER WHAT IT IS, WHETHER I
LIKE IT OR NOT.
I HAVEN'T HEARD A SINGLE PERSON
ASKED THE OBVIOUS QUESTION, WHAT
IS THE EFFECT OF GIVING PER
HORMONE SUPPRESSING DRUGS
VOLUNTARILY TO CHILDREN?
>> I THINK IT'S A LONG-TERM
EFFECT.
FIRST OF ALL, PUBERTY BLOCKERS,
THAT FOLLOWED BY HORMONE THERAPY
AS THEY ENTER ADOLESCENCE CAN
LEAD TO NEUROLOGICAL PROBLEMS,
PROBLEMS WITH BONE GROWTH AND
STERILITY LATER ON.
SO THAT IS JUST THE PHYSICAL
ISSUE.
THERE'S ALSO THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
IMPACT AND THE NEUROLOGICAL
IMPACT OF HAVING TRANSITION
SOMEONE WHO MAY DECIDE LATER ON
THAT THEY WANT TO GO BACK THE
OTHER WAY.
OF COURSE WE SHOULD SUPPORT
TRANSGENDER CHILDREN.
OF COURSE WE SHOULD SUPPORT A
CHILD'S TOYS AND THAT IS WHAT
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS SAYS.
BUT WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT GIVING
THESE DRUGS, THESE HORMONES, I
GET VERY NERVOUS.
AND I THINK TO MYSELF, WHO IS
SUPERIMPOSING THEIR WILL, IS IT
DOCTORS OR PARENTS?
BECAUSE AGAIN, A CHILD IS
SOMEONE I WANT TO
WATCH DEVELOP.
THERE'S NO QUESTION TO BE
QUESTIONING SEXUALITY AND TOYS
AND A 9-YEAR-OLD, WE HAVE TO
WAIT AND SEE WHICH WAY IT GOES.
>> Tucker: IT ALMOST SOUNDS
LIKE MUNCHAUSEN BY PROXY.
BUT IT DOESN'T SEEM RESPONSIBLE
AT ALL AND IT SEEMS INCREDIBLY
RISKY.
IT SEEMS DEMENTED TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU.
>> 1100 ADULTS WROTE A LETTER
SAYING WE DON'T AGREE WITH THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS.
AND BY THE WAY,
YOUR POINT ABOUT MUNCHAUSEN
BY PROXY IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
PARENTS SAY, MAYBE I'M NOT DOING
ENOUGH.
MAYBE WE REALLY AREN'T --
THIS IS OUR CULTURE NOW, WE HAVE
TO LISTEN TO EVERY WORD.
BUT OUR JOB AS PARENTS IS TO
GUIDE AND SUPPORT, NOT TO BE
MEAN BUT SUPPORT AND WATCH
DEVELOP MEANT IN PROGRESS.
I DON'T THINK WE LOOK FOR DRUGS
OR DOCTORS THAT DO OUR BIDDING
FOR US.
THERE IS A LONG-TERM EFFECT
HERE.
>> Tucker: IS SO IF YOU WERE
TO STAND UP AT A MEDICAL
CONFERENCE AND SAY WHAT YOU JUST
DID WHICH WAS -- IT DOESN'T SEEM
CONTROVERSIAL, HOW WOULD YOU BE
RECEIVED?
>> IT DEPENDS ON THE CONFERENCE.
I HAVE A FEELING THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS ARE
TRYING TO PANDER TO A CERTAIN
GROUP,
BUT I THINK A LOT OF DOCTORS
WOULD AGREE WITH ME, DO NO HARM.
WE ARE NOT DEALING WITH THE
DISEASE, WE ARE DEALING WITH THE
DEVELOPING CHILD.
LET THEM DEVELOP AND SUPPORT
THEIR PSYCHOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENT.
AND BY THE WAY, TO YOUR EARLIER
POINT, WHEN WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT ATHLETICS, I BELIEVE IT'S
A COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE TO ALLOW
SOMEONE THAT IS BORN A MALE, AND
HAD ALL THESE YEARS OF
TESTOSTERONE BUILDING UP MUSCLE
AND BONE, AND THEN WE ALLOW THEM
TO COMPETE WITH WHITE MEN,
THAT'S GIVING THEM A COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE AND A CALL THAT
JUICING.
WELL, OF COURSE IT IS, THAT IS